[Musica]
[Applauso]
Beh devo dire Tutto è iniziato da questa
da una scatola dovrei dire più
precisamente dal cartone come poi hanno
detto insomma
ma la verità è che insomma io non è che
sono proprio scultrice ci prova Ecco mi
arrabatto però la verità è che insomma
sono sono un operaia Sì insomma non so
dopo un comico un astrofisico e un
sindaco il migliore del mondo pare che
insomma ecco
che ansia No aspetta un attimo che devo
dire Che devo fare ricorso Comunque sì
la verità è che io faccio l'operaio Sì
faccio l'operaio in una in una GDO
qualcuno di voi sa che cos'è una GDO
Vabbè
è la grande distribuzione organizzata se
non sapete cos'è sicuramente ci siete
entrati almeno una volta nella vostra
vita e qualcuno secondo me ci passa
anche molti weekend Ecco però vabbè
andiamo avanti Insomma come hanno detto
per lunghi anni io ho fatto la
scenografa e Però nonostante ciò non
sono mai riuscita a farlo diventare un
vero e proprio lavoro almeno Insomma da
mantenermi un po' perché ti pagano poco
insomma un po' perché ti pagano in
ritardo e sei lì che dice Ah sì ma Ah sì
quel lavoro lì è vero è vero Ok l'ho
fatto l'ho fatto è vero e
e poi non ti pagano cioè la vendita dire
anche questo che non ti pagano e quindi
insomma per me questa cosa ha inciso
negli anni Anche perché suppongo
conosciate No quella quella gioia
Insomma quella bellezza no di quando
trovi nella bocchetta delle lettere e la
bolletta insomma E quindi questa cosa
almeno per me mi ha fatto intraprendere
altri lavori come come quella appunto
oggi nella GDO Ecco e però quando decisi
di quasi abbandonare la scenografia per
me fu un momento difficile perché
persino gli stimoli per la forza
l'entusiasmo
Perché non mi sentivo parte del sistema
perché il sistema mi aveva dimostrato e
mi dimostrava di non apprezzare le mie
conoscenze le mie competenze Creative ma
preferiva le altre quelle che appunto mi
facevano pagare le bollette
questo nel tempo mi ha spinto parecchio
a riflettere sulla mia persona su come
sono su come sono all'interno di questa
società
E questa scatola diciamo questo
materiale mi ha aiutato a vedere le cose
in modo diverso da una nuova prospettiva
una prospettiva che non avevo
minimamente considerato e
accade proprio in una GDO a lavoro ero
lì che caricavo i banchi di vendita e a
un certo punto vedi questo questo enorme
bancale di cartone un gigantesco insomma
E lì ci fu non so come dirvi
un'apparizione Cioè vuoi illuminata da
questa da questa visione come se fosse
come si vede come se avessi visto
Madonna no non so se avete presente
ovviamente Intendo quella che canta eh
non non l'altra eh cioè ben chiaro però
ecco quando vidi questo cartone ehm vidi
altro
vi di altre funzioni
vidi altre immagini altre possibilità
e qui ebbe l'idea avrei trasformato
questo materiale in qualcos'altro
ovviamente non sapevo come ci sarei
riuscita perché non ne avevo la benché
minima idea in quel momento però vedevo
già perché li vedevo vedevo già quelli
che oggi chiamo i recycling
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ora
grazie Ora le raffigurazioni che avete
visto Appunto nel video I recycling
nascono appunto da quelle riflessioni di
cui vi parlavo prima riflessioni su come
sono all'interno di questa società e una
società che mi ha cresciuta che ci ha
cresciuti circondati da oggetti da
prodotti usa e getta da prodotti sempre
disponibili nuovi e pronti all'uso e
recycling descrivono questo
nonostante abbiano origine da tutto
questo
sono quella nuova prospettiva che questa
scatola questo materiale mi aiuto a
vedere
decidendo di realizzare qualcosa che
avesse uno sguardo critico sui processi
di consumo in cui tutti noi Siamo
coinvolti perché sono dinamiche da cui
nessuno nessuno
e poi ne può essere a meno siamo tutti
coinvolti completamente
ora
questa scatola Se ci pensate e uno dei
materiali più usati per il
confezionamento per l'imballaggio per il
trasporto ma soprattutto per la consegna
di tantissimi prodotti oggetti che noi
acquistiamo giornalmente
è il materiale più adatto a descrivere
queste dinamiche del consumo proprio
perché considerato un semplice imballo
proprio perché considerato un
contenitore che una volta usato
Diventerà uno scarto un rifiuto
E io invece ho voluto dargli centralità
ho voluto dargli voce ho voluto farlo
parlare
e ho iniziato piano piano a bassa voce
allestendo la mia cantina trasformandola
in un laboratorio
cercando di trovare la forma più adatta
a questo materiale il mio stile la mia
forma
perché dovete sapere nel mondo
non ci sono molte persone che realizzano
sculture in cartone in Italia siamo meno
di 5
e quindi
ho dovuto usare tantissimo queste a
parte il coso qua in mano ma le mani
insomma ecco l'oro ma ho dovuto anche
usare tanto questa ma non il cervello è
per carità non passi che sia
intelligente Ecco non mi permetterei ma
quello che voglio dire è che ho dovuto
inventarmi Ecco e ho iniziato da cose
molto piccole
la cosa è molto piccola e piano piano Ho
cercato di farle diventare sempre più
grandi
e sperimentando e inventando sempre
nuove cose e dopo un anno di esercizi
Insomma di
sperimentazioni e è arrivato antitesis
ora o Caspita qua sembra grande
veramente quanto lo è Insomma però in
realtà è alto un metro e ottanta e
dell'argo 6 metri Ho impiegato un anno
per realizzarlo ma
quello che volevo raccontare in questa
installazione e la costante antitesi in
cui noi viviamo in questa società un noi
rappresentato dalla figura bianca in
preda questi contrasti che giornalmente
quotidianamente questa società ci pone
contrasti che possono essere etici
morali
sentimentali emotivi anche politici
Insomma un noi in preda questi contrasti
dove L'unica cosa che possiamo fare
oltre a quella di resistere e decidere
da quale parte lasciarci andare oppure
lasciar decidere al sistema e la società
nella direzione in cui dobbiamo andare
dopo antitesis ho voluto approfondire il
concetto del consumo e della società e
Dopo tanti mesi è arrivato primo
[Risate]
[Applauso]
primo
qui volevo raccontare
quella che io chiamo e definisco la
formula del tutto e subito una formula
che ha generato in noi la possibilità la
voglia il desiderio di poter avere
qualsiasi cosa nel modo più veloce e
facile accessibile
possiamo avere qualsiasi cosa quando la
vogliamo
Pensate ai cibi possiamo avere qualsiasi
alimento in qualunque periodo dell'anno
possiamo avere le fragole il melone a
gennaio no anche se poi non sanno di
niente Perché per carità non sanno di
niente però insomma noi ce li abbiamo
perché possiamo avere tutto e subito
questa formula
è entrata così radicalmente nel nostro
modo di vivere nel nostro modo di
pensare nel nostro modo di sentire
che ha cambiato anche i nostri rapporti
umani
Facendoci diventare prodotti che
scambiano altri prodotti e una volta
usati vengono cambiati buttati
questa formula che si sposa
con il consumo ci presenta la felicità
sotto forma di beni materiali
e noi acquistiamo più di quello che
realmente ci serve
consumiamo più di quello che realmente
abbiamo bisogno
ma queste cose ci servono davvero
ne migliorano davvero le nostre vite
e poi mi domando ma questi oggetti che
compriamo dove vanno a finire
come dove vengono smaltiti
che impatto hanno sul nostro ambiente
credo che sia una cosa su cui dovremmo
davvero pensarci
dopo primo sono andata avanti ho
realizzato altri recycling e altri ne
realizzerò perché non mi fermerò qua
perché per me Ormai è diventato oltre
che un gesto creativo o come venire
sempre definito una passione
ma per me è diventato quasi come una
forma di attivismo
un volontariato ovviamente visivo che
però possa essere utile a tutti noi che
possa essere utile socialmente
è l'unico mio piccolo contributo che che
posso dare cercando di dare valore e
significato a partire da uno scarto uno
scarto che che dovrebbe anzi che
racconterà
la società per come me e non come
dovrebbe essere
e le Cycling descriveranno proprio
questo descriveranno tutti i nostri
privilegi di cui godiamo e forse alle
volte non ci rendiamo conto di averli
descriveranno Di quanto il consumo
condizioni le nostre vite Non solo a
livello emotivo ma anche a livello
psicologico e di quanto inquilino questo
pianeta
e io lo provo a fare insomma
ci provo ci provo a farlo nell'unico
modo che sono capace insomma
creando
Ora
vorrei concludere sì
e vi vorrei ringraziare dopo il sindaco
Insomma dopo tutti quegli altri insomma
ecco adesso lo tocca anche a me quindi
ecco mi chiamo Assunta
faccio l'operaia ma sono Oma e realizzo
sculture in cartone Grazie
[Applauso]